i want to say this about these hearings
they had you know zuckerberg and dorsey
and it is
a big waste of time i don't believe
anyone's going to do anything
the republicans go i'm grandstanding
listen to me
you censor people take my space man
there you go and that's it
remember tucker carlson i think it was
jim jordan or kevin mccarthy on
and he's like okay we're having an
investigation this is ridiculous and
tucker's like
you've had four years yeah what are you
doing now like
are you kidding me and he'd have an
answer there's a big because they don't
want to
they don't care they they're like that's
what i was saying about they just look
at you like ratings
and right now these republicans in
congress are giving a good
show i'm addressing your concerns no
you're not did you see the texas crew
on twitter ted cruz gave a two and a
half minute impassioned speech about how
the democrats were
uh trying to subvert our democracy and
our speech and it was but there was it
was just ted cruz talking like there was
no i was like okay i'm gonna see the
people the things they're saying that
he's complaining about none of that it
was just
people realizing that they fight in
public
and they'll laugh at you behind your
back yeah that it's all a show
and they all collude what do we do
except for trump
i think he lasts behind her back i don't
think so he's laughing in front of us
too yeah
yeah i think i think trump is just
straight up insulting people laughing
but i tell you this behind behind closed
doors i know trump's really angry with
and pointing the finger out and laughing
at
the establishment the intelligence
agencies not the regular people
but i look at people like hillary
clinton she's the kind of person what
was that
you know that story where she was like a
plane and it was with the air force
and she held up her wine glass and went
to like an
air force like officers yeah commander
like
give me more wine and he's like what
what like i'm
i'm i'm in the air force flying a plane
you're on the
and she was like get it get it out of my
cauldron go get me yeah
get me one ladle full of my pouch what
about when she was first lady and she
was telling the secret service to carry
her bags and they're like man we need
our hands
yeah free so we can protect you and
she's like well what the f good are you
then
yes she's the kind of person who behind
goes behind closed doors and laughs
about the rebel
i don't see trump as being like that no
well trump trump would complain about
his servants
if he was in the private sector no no
well i don't know
i'm just we're all i'm not assuming no
no no no no no no no no no no no
i've gone wait i've gone i've gone to
trump tower
and asked the people who worked there
they love the man they
love him talk about what he says behind
their back though sure sure i don't
think he's a very nice guy
hillary clinton she's telling a story
where she's like carrying mine she's a
straight up
i don't think look trump probably talks
smack about everybody
but here's the thing he we know he does
so that's the thing
i don't think trump is is is making fun
of mocking and bullying bullying regular
people
when he's a guy who's when he eats fast
food all the time and he does and he
always has
i don't see him as the guy coming out
and going like these disgusting filth
peasants eating their disgusting food no
he's going to mcdonald's
so so he does kind of rag on a lot of
people he's got a mouth on him
but hillary clinton and probably joe
biden and a lot of these people are the
romney
romney
definitely yeah the the the 47 percent
was that was that romney yeah
when he's like yeah they the rebel
heaven forbid they get in our rooms
donald trump has mcdonald's at the white
house for regular people he has well
done steak with ketchup and mitt romney
won't even drink caffeine
right wow yeah freak religion well
donald
isn't donald trump like he's never had
alcohol he's never had drugs that's
supposed to be that's a lie
that's a lie really there's a book uh my
buddy allen salkin wrote about i forgot
what's called the basically
the the method to his madness and it
talked about back in the day he'd be at
the
down at the club and he'd have you know
champagne or wine in his hand so he says
he's a tea toddler
but apparently he's a freaking liar he
was a he was a germaphobe
yes okay so he avoids alcohol because
his brother died of alcoholism-related
but i mean
you would think i could understand how
after that you would never drink again
but before that
i think he well alcoholism ran in their
family didn't it his brother was a
stupid his dad was a
yeah fred that makes sense to me michael
assuming that all these people are crazy
yes psychopaths
they're not crazy representatives uh
what's the answer
i'm not allowed to say oh give me a
little no we'll get banned just slide it
over
come on um do you mean like what kind of
trebuchet
yeah no no no no no no no no
what angle no what's the gravity no no
nope um where are we going no i'm going
to be serious
um i think that i'm talking about this
in my next book that i'm writing now
which is being it's taking forever to
write
the point is because people a lot like
talk about it's like 1984 it's very
orwellian
and i've always maintained it's much
closer to brave new world by aldous
huxley
where the elites rule not through force
not through threats of force
but by using pleasure yeah by keeping
you numb
you know watch these stupid movies pills
literal pills yeah
yeah and i think it's going to be very
easy once people
realize wait a minute like these people
are
horrible and they don't represent me i
have nothing in common with them
why am i locked in my house while
gretchen whitmer is doing whatever she
wants getting botoxed on her yacht
this is not happening and i think it is
this is why
this is i'm having distance i'm having
ish
and i sound like joe biden now i can't
even say it uh in too much pizza
yeah or not enough um it's hard for me
to reconcile
how submissive and servile so many
americans have been over this past year
throughout this country
with the reaction to the election which
has been
very historical on the right very much
not even a pretense of like we're going
to listen to this that
like it's being regarded as a complete
farce yeah that i don't know how to
reconcile those two things
this is kind of crazy because uh uh one
of the reasons i didn't vote in 2016 is
that i have absolutely no faith
in the electoral process i was like
what's the point you know the
the two-party system the people you want
they never get elected they lie they get
elected then they do whatever they want
they appoint the same people and then
all of a sudden
donald trump got elected and i was like
wow i was laughing this dude kicked in
the doors what are people saying it's a
bull in the cathedral he's running
around stopping the china shop yeah yeah
i say bull in the ivory tower but you
know cathedral probably works better
because it encompasses more than just uh
yeah hollywood's not the ivory tower
right and hollywood's a major part of
this
right so trump kicks in the door and
then all of a sudden i'm like hey well i
guess you can win
now things are kind of different because
at first i was thinking like
you can you can actually win the system
you know actually works
now i'm looking at everything that's
going on right now clearly the system
isn't working
i mean well i shouldn't say it that way
what i should say is the
the the front door of the machine is
in not opening i guess i don't i don't
say the
machine is broken the system is working
because trump is going through all these
processes
but clearly it's not what anyone
expected
you'd vote we're done have a nice day
now it's just the craziest election of
my life
trump taught the out group and i don't
mean just repel right you know certain
republicans i mean like
leftists who are part of the who are
like the bernie people who got kicked
out of the process in 2016 and 2020
especially
he taught them we can win and he also
taught them even if we lose we can have
a lot of fun
and make some really bad people really
upset
as part of the process and that's a bell
they can't unring
and that's really freaking them out
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you